[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
johanna paare zusammen und herzlich
willkommen es war ein spannender letzter
bundesliga spieltag und den gibt's
gleich von norbert lehmann aufmerksam
gefasst
schauen wir auf die großen themen heute
wackelt der nato beitritt von finnland
und schweden vor dem treffen der
außenminister in berlin kündigt die
türkei bedenken an
geländegewinne für die ukraine wo sich
die russen begriff zurückziehen bleiben
trümmer und zerstörung
das leiden jesu als friedensappell in
oberammergau starten die weltberühmten
passionsspiele
in berlin treffen sich die
außenministerin und minister der nato
über den ukraine krieg zu beraten und
über eine damit zusammenhängende
erweiterung des militärbündnisses
denn das bislang neutrale finnland will
der nato beitreten schweden dürfte bald
nachziehen der rest so dachte man nur
noch formalität alle 30 mitgliedsstaaten
müssen dem beitrittsgesuch zustimmen ein
land deutet jetzt aber an die
nato-erweiterung zumindest nicht einfach
so durchzuwinken und zwar ist dass die
türkei der grund die beiden
skandinavischen länder sollen
terroristen beherbergen so der türkische
präsident erdogan gemeint sind etwa
anhänger der kurdischen pkk andreas
künast aus berlin
bis gestern mittag war sich finnlands
aussenminister sicher dass der beitritt
zur nato historisch ein riesenschritt
aber praktisch nur ein schrittchen ist
reine formsache hatte die nato gesagt
und nun das
natürlich hat jedes der 30 nato länder
die möglichkeit den prozess zu
blockieren
deshalb versuchen wir gute kontakte zu
jedem zu halten das ist anders rum nicht
so an finnlands und schwedens umgang mit
der pkk stört sich die türkei und stellt
überraschend deren nato-beitritt in
frage
skandinavische länder sind gasthäuser
für terrororganisationen wie die pkk
für die 29 anderen nato-staaten wäre ein
veto der türkei ein desaster das treffen
in berlin sollte geschlossenheit
demonstrieren nun herrschen ratlosigkeit
zum teil wut
die deutsche außenministerin beendet am
morgen den g 7 gipfel in weißen haus
dankt ihren mitarbeitern und wirbt für
die vergrößerung der nato und auch
diesem grund sollte eigentlich jedes
demokratische land darüber erfreut sein
dass demokratien mit starken
verteidigungsfähigkeiten damit auch
unser gemeinsames verteidigungsbündnis
stärker machen würden im kreml ruft am
mittag finnlands präsidentin den s t an
und wird von vladimir putin gewandt ein
nato beitritt werde die beziehungen
beider länder verschlechtern der
finnische und die schwedische
außenministerin wollen in berlin mit der
türkei reden und versuchen diese
spannungen abzubauen
die türkei meldet also bedenken an gegen
einen nato-beitritt finnlands und
schwedens florian reagieren die anderen
nato-partner darauf
erst mal haben die äußerungen hierfür
sehr viele irritationen gesorgt im kreis
der anderen 29 nato partner denn in der
tat bis gestern morgen war man davon
ausgegangen dass dieser zu diesen ort
erweiterung ohne vorbehalte von allen 29
39 staaten der nato durchgewunken werden
würde jetzt also diese aufregung die man
heute aber versucht spürbar herunter zu
regeln der finnische außenminister ließ
sich hier heute so zitieren er sei
weiterhin optimistisch dass sein am ende
der nato beitreten könne und auch der
wichtigste außenpolitische berater des
türkischen präsidenten erdogan ließ sich
heute so zitieren sein land schließe die
tür zur nato eben nicht man wolle aber
über die präsenz der verbotenen
kurdischen terrororganisation pkk in den
beiden ländern schweden und finnland
verhandeln und gerade eben vor wenigen
sekunden trat dann der türkische
außenminister davutoglu hier vor die
presse klang wiederum etwas weniger
versöhnlich es bleibt also spannend und
die große frage bleibt was will die
türkei eigentlich erreichen was sie
schon mal erreicht hat ist die große
aufmerksamkeit auf der internationalen
bühne einschätzung von feuer haben
dankeschön
zur nato gehören das will auch ein land
weiter südöstlich georgien ein teil der
republik will aber das gegenteil den
anschluss an russland und die abspaltung
von georgien es geht um die kaukasus
region südossetien
etwa so groß wie mallorca die führung
dort hat nun beschlossen im juli soll
ein referendum die zugehörigkeit zu
russland besiegeln moskau hat seit dem
georgien krieg 2008 die kontrolle über
südossetien nur wenige länder haben die
region als unabhängigen staat anerkannt
in der ukraine gehen die kämpfe mit
aller härte weiter
dabei ist schwer zu beurteilen welche
seite geländegewinne im osten erzielt
anders dagegen die lage weiter nördlich
vor allem bei der lange belagerten
großstadt kharkiv können die
ukrainischen truppen offenbar dorf um
dort von den russischen besatzern
zurückerobern manche erst jetzt andere
wie etwa maler johann schon zuvor unsere
reporterin katrin eigendorf waren der
region und berichtet von trümmern und
von light
ein russischer panzer mitten im dorf
müller horn überall in den dörfern aus
denen die ukrainische armee putins
truppen zurückgedrängt hat spuren der
zerstörung
inzwischen trauen sich die menschen
wieder heraus
wir hatten große angst man sagt die
russin benehmen sich nicht gut alle
saßen in ihren häusern
jetzt wird klar nichts wird mehr wie es
war die schule die juliana besucht hat
ist zerstört
niemand darf ins gebäude dort könnte
immer noch munition liegen die
russischen soldaten haben nicht nur ihre
häuser zerstört im dorf wieliczka so
heißt es wurden über 100 menschen nach
russland verschleppt
anatolische kriegen erzählt wie die
russischen soldaten seine familie
mitgenommen haben angeblich um sie in
sicherheit zu bringen
meine schwiegertochter meine enkelin die
kleine mein sohn und meine frau und
haben sie keinen kontakt nein keine
koordinaten keine daten nichts meine
enkelin das ist besonders schlimm der
familienvater nimmt uns mit ins haus
zeigt uns das foto von veronika seine
achtjährige enkelin war sein ein und
alles und nun ist nur das foto geblieben
verzeihen sie aber wenn ich auf ihre
augen schaue dann beginne ich zu weinen
ein ganzes leben dass sich der 67
jährige bauer aufgebaut hat liegt in
trümmern zum abschied freut mich anatoli
ob er mich in den arm nehmen darf kann
ich in diesem augenblick nicht tun
das auch durch den ukraine krieg
weltweit gestiegenen weizenpreise es hat
indien mit sofortiger wirkung den export
von weizen untersagt das land für so
sicherstellen selbst genügend weizen zu
haben dass wegen einer hitzewelle
größere ernteausfälle befürchtet kritik
an dem schritt kommt von den g7
agrarministerinnen und minister wir
rufen dazu auf die märkte offen zu
halten sagte landwirtschaftsminister
erste mal
in den usa werden heute hunderttausende
menschen zu demonstrationen für eine
recht auf abtreibungen erwartet anlass
ist ein durch gestochene urteilsentwurf
des obersten gerichtshofs der das
bundesweite weiter recht auf
schwangerschaftsabbruch kippen würde das
seit fast 50 jahren in den usa gilt
sollte es dazu kommen drohen die
protestierenden bereits mit einem sommer
der wut m at wissen sie hätten nie
gedacht dass sie wieder demonstrieren
müssen mutter nancy und tochter molly in
den 80er jahren als das abtreibungsrecht
schon einmal auf dem spiel stand
das ist eine kleine gruppe von menschen
die andere manipulieren und die lügen
und dann nehmen sie uns unsere rechte
weg
die minderheit wie das sagen haben im
land jetzt wird es klar und es ist
erschreckend
es sollen heute zehntausende werden in
washington hunderttausende im ganzen
land sie sind aufgebracht auch wegen der
scharfen worte im durch gestochenen
entwurf das urteil von 1973 sei durch
keine verfassungsrechtliche vorschrift
entdeckt ein beispiel für die ausübung
juristischer macht kommt das urteil
könnte jeder bundesstaat den
schwangerschaftsabbruch selbst regeln
bisher ist er bis zur 20 oder 24 woche
erlaubt etwa die hälfte der staaten will
abtreibung fast unmöglich machen einige
wollen gar frauen bestrafen die in
anderen staaten hilfe suchen jeder soll
gegen kliniken klagen dürfen im
restaurant wollen wir das recht auf
leben in der verfassung absichern
liberale bundesstaaten connecticut
bieten hilfe suchenden frauen nun einen
gesetzlichen schutz vor klagen rund 60
prozent der amerikaner sind für ein
liberaleres abtreibungsrecht
im juni wird das urteil verkündet in
dutzenden großstädten der usa wollen sie
heute gehört werden und dann weiter
kämpfen für die rechte der frauen
nach deutschland
endspurt vor der landtagswahl am sonntag
in nordrhein westfalen
dort haben die parteien heute noch
einmal um stimmen geworben die cdu will
weiterregieren mit ministerpräsident
wüst die spd hofft mit ihrem
spitzenkandidaten kutschaty auf einen
wechsel in der düsseldorfer
staatskanzlei wie die wahl im
bevölkerungsreichsten bundesland ausgeht
wird auch in berlin mit spannung
beobachtet geht sie doch als wichtiger
stimmungstest für die bundespartei
und in düsseldorf ist für uns bettina
schausten es sieht alles nach einem
wirklich sehr enge rennen zwischen cdu
und spd aus
ja so ist es ja nur 13 millionen
wahlberechtigte im einwohnerstärksten
deutschen bundesland die nrw wahl wird
ja gerne eine kleine bundestagswahl
genannt und hat durchaus testcharakter
für die stimmung auch im bund der
cdu-ministerpräsident hendrik wüst hat
sich hier im land in nur gut sechs
monaten einen ganz ordentlichen
amtsbonus erarbeitet aber kann sich eben
nicht weit absetzen von der spd mit
thomas kutschaty und so hat die spd hier
die chance in ihrer ehemaligen
herzkammer wieder an die macht zu kommen
selbst wenn sie nicht stärkste kraft
wird die grünen als absehbar größte
gewinner morgen werden am ende wohl
darüber entscheiden wer
ministerpräsident wird die jetzige
regierung schwarz gelb das ist ziemlich
sicher wird wegen der schwäche der fdp
nicht weitermachen können den liberalen
droht ein weiterer bitterer wahlabend ja
den lohnt es sich in jedem fall mit uns
zu verfolgen wir melden uns morgen ab 17
uhr 35 hier aus dem zdf wahlstudio im
düsseldorfer landtag dankeschön bettina
schausten
die schriftstellervereinigung pen steht
vor einem scherbenhaufen nach dem
rücktritt des journalisten dennis
mitchell soll nun ein interimsvorstand
den neuanfang organisieren
gestern waren bei der
mitgliederversammlung monatelange
interne auseinandersetzungen um die
ausrichtung eskaliert neben michelle war
auch das komplette präsidium
zurückgetreten penn gilt weltweit als
stimme verfolgter und unterdrückte
autorinnen und autoren
immer mehr rentner innen gehen arbeiten
im vergangenen jahr waren es nach
angaben der bundesregierung gut eine
million menschen über 67 jahren die
einer beschäftigung nachgingen die
meisten hatten einen minijob und es
werden seit jahren immer mehr der
linke-bundestagsabgeordnete
pellmann bezeichnete das als traurige
entwicklung das rentensystem sichere den
lebensstandard der bürger kaum noch
millionen menschen in deutschland haben
in diesen tagen post bekommen die
aufforderung am zensus teilzunehmen es
ist eine art inventur früher sagte man
dazu landläufig volkszählung erfasst
werden beispielsweise daten zur
bevölkerungszahl wohnsituation
ausbildung arglos wegwerfen sollte man
die fragebögen nicht denn ab morgen
beginnt der zensus und die teilnahme ist
verpflichtend
weitere einzelheiten von stefan
schlosser
schon seit monaten werden in ganz
deutschland wie hier in bad schwalbach
in wiesbaden so genannte
erhebungsbeauftragte
geschult sie sollen in den kommenden
wochen haushalte besuchen und daten
abfragen das geht ganz schnell und ganz
flott ich habe schon zu hause geübt mit
meinen zwillingen und
alles wie sie fünf minuten und ja bei
den haushalten befragt werden 10,3
millionen bürger und bürgerinnen
zufällig ausgewählt dazu kommen rund 23
millionen haus- und wohnungseigentümer
vorhandenen der daten aus den registern
der verwaltung werden ebenfalls genutzt
die ergebnisse des zensus dienen als
grundlage für viele wichtige politische
entscheidungen das fängt an beim
finanzausgleich das zieht sich über die
zahl der bundesrat setzte oder auch die
den zuschnitt der wahlkreise und kommt
dann letztlich auch in den kommunen als
wichtige planungsgrundlage zum tragen
wenn es zum beispiel um die zahl der
kita-plätze geht oder schulen
abgefragt werden persönliche daten wie
name geschlecht und geburtsdatum angaben
zur ausbildung beruf und zur
wohnsituation
vermögensverhältnisse oder zum beispiel
gesundheitsdaten werden nicht erfasst
der zugriff von unberechtigten ist
sicher ausgeschlossen und die daten die
erhoben werden werden schnellstmöglich
anonymisiert können dann nicht mehr zu
einzelnen personen zurückverfolgt werden
die teilnahme ist verpflichtend und kann
auch online durchgeführt werden wer sich
weigert wird mehrfach aufgefordert am
ende droht sogar ein zwangsgeld von rund
300 euro
normalerweise finden sie alle zehn jahre
statt die passionsspiele in dem kleinen
oberbayerischen dorf oberammergau den
corona wurden sie noch mal um zwei jahre
verschoben jetzt gibt es keine auflagen
und die aufführungen können voll gesetz
stattfinden entstanden sind die
passionsspiele vor fast 400 jahren
damals gelobten die oberammergauer das
leiden und sterben christi aufzuführen
wenn niemand mehr an der pest sterben
sollte und so kam es tatsächlich
christiane hast recht und barbara lueg
berichten
endlich premiere endlich wieder getümmel
heute im bayerischen oberammergau
mittendrin regisseur christian stückl
und über 4000 zuschauer gespannt auf die
große passion
für jesus darsteller frederik ist die
botschaft die von hier in die welt soll
klar
dass man den anderen so behandelt wie
man selbst behandelt werden und ich
glaube wenn jeder so leben würde so
handeln würde oder es zumindest
probieren würde würden wir in einer
besseren welt lägen seit über einem jahr
darf in oberammergau niemand mehr zum
friseur damit die geschichte noch
wahrhaftiger wird die bewohner nehmen
das pestgelübde ernst ihr versprechen
die tradition seit generationen spielt
das ganze dorf mit alte junge babys das
schweißt zusammen
jesus mein opa zweimal pilatus hauptmann
mein vater spielt jetzt wieder den
pilatus war der verkäufer oder so
früher durften hier nur katholiken
mitspielen später auch protestanten
diesmal übernimmt erstmals ein muslim
eine hauptrolle der oberammergauer
dennis bührer feiert als judas
vor einer stunde große pause und erste
eindrücke einfach unvergleichlich
da stand mir das alles einmal doch die
träne im auge super also wunderbar
richtig richtig ergreifend richtig toll
rund 100 vorstellungen folgen jetzt sie
sollen vor allem aufruf zur überwindung
von gewalt seien gerade jetzt
[Musik]
jetzt kommen wir wie versprochen zum
letzten spieltag der fußball bundesliga
mit den letzten wichtigen entscheidungen
vor allen dingen ein wahrer
abstiegs-krimi heute nachmittag denn
lange zeit sah es nach dem klassenerhalt
für härte aus dann aber machte der bvb
das siegtor in der 84 minute gegen die
berliner und stuttgart gelang dann die
sensation klassenerhalt für den vfb
durch ein last minute siegtor gegen köln
damit muss härter in die relegation hier
die ergebnisse dieses 34 spieltags der
bvb schlägt härter also mit 221
stuttgart gewinnt gegen köln ebenfalls 2
1 wolfsburg und bayern trennen sich
unentschieden 2 2 schützenfest im
borussia-park gladbach schlägt
hoffenheim mit 5 zu 1 mainz und
frankfurt trennten sich 2 2 leverkusen
besiegte freiburg mit 2 1 1 1 1
unentschieden zwischen bielefeld und
leipzig union gegen bochum 3 2 und
schliesslich augsburg gegen fürth zwei
zu eins blick auf die tabelle die bayern
zum zehnten mal in folge meister
dortmund zum achten mal in der
bundesliga-geschichte vizemeister
leverkusen und leipzig spielen in der
champions league union und freiburg in
der europa league und köln als siebter
in der konferenz league mit gladbach
beginnt die zweite tabellenhälfte und im
keller hat ja wie schon gesagt stuttgart
als fünfzehnter den klassenerhalt
geschafft hertha muss in die relegation
bielefeld und führt sind abgestiegen
ja die bundesliga sie so also vorbei und
zwei trainer werfen das handtuch bei
ihren vereinen adi hütter bei borussia
mönchengladbach und markus weinzierl
beim fc augsburg alle spiele alle tore
dieses verrückten letzten spieltag
später bei uns im aktuellen sportstudio
um 23 uhr zu gast bei jochen breyer der
sportdirektor von wiederaufsteiger
schalke 04 rouven schröder
olympiasieger alexander zverev hat beim
tennis turnier in rom das finale
verpasst der hamburger verlor in einem
spannenden halbfinal duell gegen den
griechen stefanos city pass mit 6 4 3 6
3 6
alexander zverev vorne im bild hatte den
ersten satz 6 4 gewonnen dann allerdings
kommt der frost city pass immer besser
ins spiel gleicht nach sätzen aus dieser
break des griechen zum 3 2 im dritten
satz gibt letztlich das match zu dessen
gunsten
insgesamt ein hochklassiges halbfinale
bei sommerlichen temperaturen in rom
alexander zverev nach dem break
unkonzentrierter kann nicht mehr
gegenhalten zum achten mal in insgesamt
zwölf begegnungen gewinnt der grieche
gegen den deutschen kein finale also für
zverev aber eine gute vorbereitung für
das bevorstehende grand slam turnier in
paris
auftakt der eishockey wm in finnland
deutschland musste gestern abend im
ersten spiel gleich gegen
titelverteidiger kanada ran und verlor
mit 3 5 der rekord-weltmeister ging
bereits im ersten drittel mit 2 0 in
führung danach das erste tor für
deutschland durch michael ist zum 1 2
dann aber bauten die kanadier die
führung auf 5 1 aus im letzten drittel
deutschland dann noch mit zwei toren
seidler zum 3 5-endstand
und heute abend gleich das nächste
gruppenspiel deutschland gegen die
slowakei
und jetzt blicken wir noch mal nach
ostengland denn da beginnt ein
kunstfestival und ganz neue system
domino waren denn die domino bahn läuft
überall durch die stadt durch wohnhäuser
gärten und ein einkaufszentrum sogar in
einem pub heißes in bitte von über
kippen 7000 quade aus bimsstein plus 200
helferinnen und helfer und tausende
zuschauende ergibt eine wirklich
bewerten
nach einem trockenen sonnigen tag morgen
folgen gewitter am montag ausführlich
das ganze gleich von christa haben
marietta slomka hat gegen viertel vor
elf das heute-journal für sie es morgen
wenn sie mögen
[Musik]